die serie emily in paris schoss kurz
nach serien start auf platz 1 der
netflix top ten
die hauptdarstellerin lily collins ist
dabei aber keine newcomerin
die britin ist die tochter von musik
legende phil collins
der ist nicht nur ein megastar und oscar
preisträger sondern hat lilly auch früh
ein echtes glamour leben und treffen mit
stars wie justin timberlake ermöglicht
nach der scheidung ihrer eltern zog
lilly mit ihrer mutter nach arbeitete
als journalistin für die teen vogue elle
girl und altheim und berichtete mit nur
19 jahren für nickelodeon von obamas
amtseinführung aus dem weißen haus
parallel passiert lilith die schon mit
zwei jahren für die britische serie
growing pains vor der kamera stand ihre
karriere als schauspielerin ihre erste
größere filmrolle bekamen sie dann mit
20 jahren als tochter von sandra bullock
in blind side die große chance
mittlerweile war sie schon in
zahlreichen filmen unter anderem an der
seite von stars wie julia roberts oder
zac efron
außerdem wurde das multitalent von
designer karl lagerfeld als model
entdeckt für lilly war der modezar
später sowohl ideell als auch freund
aktuell ist lilly frisch verlobt mit dem
regisseur charlie mcdowell
und noch eine andere promi tochter
schafft es zum großen durchbruch
schauspielerin kate hudson ist die
tochter von hollywood ikone goldie hawn
und kam bereits im kindesalter mit dem
filmgeschäft in berührung
ihre ersten erfahrungen vor der kamera
sammelt sie in den 90er jahren mit
kleineren filmen und serien rollen ihrer
rolle der penny lane in dem film almost
famous fast berühmt hat sie ihren
internationalen durchbruch einen golden
globe und eine oscar nominierung zu
verdanken
seither ist sie als schauspielerin
weltweit bekannt hat ihre eigene sport
bekleidungsmarke brachte eine eigene
single heraus und war zuletzt in dem
musikvideo zum song together von
sängerin ziel beim tanzen zu sehen
us sängerin miley cyrus kommt aus keiner
unbekannten familie durch ihren vater
country-sänger und schauspieler billy
ray cyrus kam sie zum singen und
schauspielern dieser förderte sie schon
früh und verschaffte ihr ihre erste
rolle in seiner krankenhaus-serie doch
später wurde miley durch die
disney-serie hannah montana
der echte vater auch ihren serien date
spielt zum weltstar
seither veröffentlichte sie mir ihre
alben und wirkte in verschiedenen filmen
und serien wie zb der netflix show
blackmore als schauspielerin mit mileys
patentante ist übrigens keine geringere
als country legende dolly parton wie es
ist eine weltweit berühmte tante zu
haben das weiß auch emma roberts als
nichte von julia roberts war sie schon
früh an verschiedenen drehorten zu
besuch und wurde so auch auf die
schauspielerei aufmerksam
obwohl ihre mutter zunächst gegen eine
filmkarriere ihrer tochter war gab ihr
filmdebüt 2001 im alter von zehn jahren
drei jahre später wurde immer mit der
rolle die singer in der nickelodeon
serie und fabolous berühmt obwohl sie
sich auch bereits als sängerin versuchte
entschied sich emma inzwischen eindeutig
für die schauspielerei sie wirkte schon
in vielen filmen wie wild child oder
neff und serien wie american horror
story mit aktuell erwartet sie ihr
erstes kind mit schauspieler garrett
hedlund auch in deutschland gibt es
einige promi kinder die sich einen namen
in der branche machen
dazu zählen zb die kinder des
schauspielers uwe ochsenknecht die als
schauspieler und models tätig sind
auch elena karriere hat einen berühmten
papa nämlich den schauspieler mathieu
carrière und geht ihren eigenen
karriereweg als model und schauspielerin
[Musik]
[Applaus]